so what are these people all united by
just having millions of dollars and
having sex with children is this seem to
be how our entire planet run I mean is a
genuinely serious question like when we
start is this who's running the planet I
mean it seems to all kind of add up
where it's like they use this you know
sick thing to keep each other in check
how do you think this all works do these
people just is this is just a way to
keep people quiet keep them in line they
all part I mean is there anybody who's
successful like is there anyone who's
not a pedophile who's doing it like you
know what I mean like well I mean I
can't really speak I can't really give
you a definitive answer to that but you
know what I can say is that you know a
lot of people in this orbit right the
this epstein Network whatever you want
to call it just have a history of just
blackmail or ties to organized crime or
ties to intelligence right right and
blackmail for these people I mean they
don't live like regular people do you
know all right so I watched her for
example right Maria farmers on his guest
house she was like normal people don't
live like this you know they spent hours
watching her through pinnable cameras in
that guest house right see everything
doing I mean that's not how normal
people live they have so much money but
they're so paranoid right I mean because
that's not like mob families are and
that's how these families are - right
and you look at someone like the
Bronfman family that's tied up in a lot
of this stuff - they were tied up in
nexium right which also had like
elements of blackmail and all of that
better - and then also like you know I'm
one of Edgar Bronfman kids tried to
blackmail him in the 1980s faking his
own kidnapping and things like that it
was on father right like more my dad
yeah like that's just all these families
just seem to operate I mean if you
almost feel bad for them but then you
realize what their horrendous evil
criminals that belong behind bars for
the rest of their lives other people
right but I mean they're just like they
don't exist like we do like regular
people do you I guess you know right -
constantly
jockeying for position it's like kind of
like Game of Thrones you have all these
powerful families they all have tons of
money they all want more money it's
never enough and any information they
have on each other or any any of these
you know elite circles that they can
penetrate there seems to be some type of
cost of admission and it might not
always be pedophilia but it also could
be like financial crime or it could be
like your willingness to you know
infiltrate a government agency and give
information it's everybody's got
something on somebody else so just lean
but you know let's keep it right to you
that like this practice of sexual
blackmail and these types of operations
including those involving children I
mean they go back to like the 1940s
right possibly even earlier right the
fact that they doing this for so long
it's just like well this is how things
are and as long as we stick you know
abide by a certain set of rules that
this group follows or whatever you know
we can you know great kids as much as
you want and stuff like that right and
you know yeah what gets me is like it's
really well it's like instead of raping
kids let's go on the boat like is there
any rich person who's like let's not
rape kids today we can have brunch like
it is there anybody should let's let's
time is crazy it's like yeah um in truly
evil human beings the Clintons and Trump
I don't want to the reason I haven't
asked you until this small in the
interview is Chi don't want this to be a
political story like I don't want it to
be politicized and become a battering
ram where people on the left go Trump
and people in the right parts right it
is bipartisan yeah right evil satanic
pedophile cabal's are bipartisan and my
audience should know that where do you
see that the cleanse of the Trump's how
are they in meshed in this are they just
kind of functionaries in terms of they
run the United States government how
close are they with these people
alright neither of them are clean but in
order to really explain the
relationships is a the relate their
relationships to this whole thing I mean
it takes some time right because the
official stories about their involvement
are just
my opinion very superficial and I guess
probably one of the easiest to start
with because the Trump lines more
complex because a lot of it precedes
2,000 right a lot of the closer
involvement between Trump and have seen
happen before them and but that's also
true for Bill Clinton great because the
the official story about you know Bill
Clinton and Epstein says that Bill
Clinton did involved with FC until he
wasn't president anymore this is
complete yes great so what we know right
as I mentioned earlier so like that the
Clintons had some involvement was
promised software stuff I mean they were
kind of in this orbit anyway nothing you
know not just to the promise but also
the iran-contra stuff which this epstein
network and the Maxwells and all the
stuff we're also involved through what
was going on in Mena Arkansas Arkansas
I mean involved in Iran Contra in a huge
way Bill Clinton had a relationship with
the CIA with Bill Casey bill Barr
actually acted as an emissary of Bill
Casey to Bill Clinton on several
occasions right another reason why he is
shaky is [ __ ] right so anyway that's how
the clip you know this is all before he
even becomes president but as soon as he
becomes president remember that Epstein
and Maxwell officially teamed up in New
York in 1991 as soon as he becomes
president in 1993 they are attending
donor dinners fancy donor dinners right
for the Clintons and not long after that
Jeffrey Epstein
that same year makes several White House
visits and he meets the WD chief of
staff on several occasions what they
discussed I don't really know but in
1995 we do know that Lynn Forrester now
Lynn Forrester de Rothschild right
sends this letter to Bill Clinton that
you can find actually was provided by
the presidential library of Bill Clinton
it says basically talks about how she
had met Bill Clinton at Senator then
senator Ted Kennedy's house and she
didn't have much time to talk to him and
had all these other things he wanted to
talk about him and she said in what she
called this this brief window of time to
talk to the president these were 15
seconds of access she talked to Bill
Clinton about two things
currency stabilization and Jeffrey
Epstein this is in 1995 in 1995
Marie afar
was decorating right and working as as
artists in residence for d'Alene Maxwell
Jeffrey Epstein she remembers more than
one occasion where everyone was ordered
out but they spent all day preparing for
Bill Clinton to come and d'Alene Maxwell
was running around yelling the president
coming and all this stuff
and the only people that were allowed to
stay was the personal chef of Epstein
who died last month under sudden
circumstances and no funeral because of
the coronavirus right
everyone's ordered out with the chef and
the girls there's no security details of
Bill Clinton and he's a sitting
president at this time right so very
strange right and this is all before the
official you know the relationship comes
out in the open and Epstein is involved
in the Clinton Foundation ghilane is
involved in the Clinton Global
Initiative all of the island visits the
flight logs and all of that takes place
right right so they're what are Hillary
and Bill doing right now I mean other
than sharpening knives what do you think
that are do you think they're do you
think you're nervous do these people get
nervous are these elites kind of like oh
well I think what the Delaine max will
arrest I don't think any of these people
are really nervous based on how this is
going to play out because I think it's
going to be a very secretive protracted
legal trial that is going to get buried
in the insane news cycle in which we now
live which involves coronavirus of civil
unrest protests major TV political
tensions I mean it's very easy to bury
the Epstein story unlike last year and
like I said it's it's very clear to me
anyway they're gonna let her post bail
and she's not going to end up in the
situation Epstein was in because
actually was only there because he
wasn't and he was denied bail do you
think they're gonna let miss lane
Maxwell the definition of a flight risk
post bail uh yeah I think wow but
because of the charges she's facing they
are so light right right in contrast to
Epstein right who last year was denied
bail because of the you know his being
the crimes were much more egregious that
he was officially charged with
right so you know to deny someone the
ability to post bail when they are only
charged with enticing minors to travel
yeah you know why did they choose those
charges specifically why didn't they
charge her with statutory rape why did
they you know keep it up 94 to 1997
right well actually I can tell you why
it's because in that period of time
Prince Andrew and alan dershowitz were
not in Bill Clinton officially we're not
on the orbit yet right so they don't
have to be drugged you know pulled into
this trial of coming trial billing
Maxwell focuses on a time when none of
them were you know officially involved
interesting so there's no chance they
get pulled into it yeah right now what
about Trump is there any chance he's
pulled into it in any way well no
because well based on these charges now
right but you know Trump in in his ex
wife Ivana were in the Epstein horbet to
a significant degree during that time
frame right Reuben Maria farmer you know
said that she personally witnessed Ivana
Trump going out with ghilane and
recruiting preteen girls and school
uniforms to come by Jeffrey Epstein's
office and you know see if they could be
future Victoria's Secret models yeah
it's really crazy Trump did kick Epstein
out of more laga because he was hitting
on an underage girl so we'll get well
there there's a longer history to them
right because it okay right so you have
to go back to the 1980s and see what FC
was doing then right so basically what
it actually was during this period of
time he was doing a lot of shady
financial activity for intelligence and
intelligence operatives but he was also
with Leslie Wexner doing a lot of one
money money laundering through real
estate and a lot of shady real estate
deals at Manhattan right of course that
trumps whole orbit too right and during
this period of time in the 1980s the
Epstein Trump in the sky named Tom
Barrett who's still pretty close to
Trump and head of Colony Capital were
called the three musketeers of New York
life nightlife because they would go to
clubs and like you know get with women
together and BC
together like so frequently and they
were all in that same you know same age
range more or less involved same shady
real estate deals and that ultimately
were a lot of that relationship comes
from though it's worth pointing out that
Maria farmer did say that in 1995 she
saw Donald Trump and he gave her this
just buried
she found it to be a very disturbing
look and the Jeffrey Epstein said the
trip oh she's not here for you implying
that there was some other type of girl
that she would that he would set Trump
up with right but this was one occasion
but it was enough to make an impact on
her right and of course there is that
accusation who this girl who claimed
that she had been raped by Trump and at
this event with Epstein in like in 1994
I believe it was so there are these
claims going around but as far as I'm
you know I I see it right a lot of their
relationship was based around the shady
real-estate stuff that FC continued to
do well into the late 1990s why it was
they were falling out between Epstein
and Trump well a lot of it had to do
with this property in Palm Beach that
Jeffrey Epstein wanted to buy ostensibly
for this money-laundering real estate
purpose or some shady real estate deal
he invites Trump to come see the
property and Trump you know says oh you
know give they talk about it whatever
and then Trump ends up stealing that
property from Epstein and doing what X
he wanted to do and sells it to like
this really rich Eastern European guy
maybe like Russian billionaire or
something like that who never actually
lives in the property but pays a bunch
of money for it and then it just gets
like the house gets demolished and you
know really shady transaction basically
of class after that apparently what
Epstein tried to do at mar-a-lago when
he was kicked out had to do with an
attempt by f seem to get back at Trump
for what had happened there and sort of
get Trump set up with a minor or have a
minor get caught in some sort of
situational situation at Mara Largo to
put pressure on Trump so this is just a
game they play this is there's just the
way that people are playing this game